[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal
astrophysicist we're going to do a
climate update this will be fast
catching up on the latest knowledge of
what the state of the world's climate is
let me bring in my co-host Paul mrio
Paul good to have you back man good to
see you so I don't how many people don't
know this but right up the street from
the American Museum of Natural History
is a branch of NASA called the Godard
Institute for space studies which
focuses primarily on planetary
atmospheres I think we can count Earth
as a planet here so that counts we have
with us and it's not his first rodeo
Gavin Schmidt Gavin welcome back to Star
Talk hi thanks a lot for having me back
there's a lot to talk about you're
you're only the third director of that
storyed institution it's been around for
at least 60 years uh that's exactly
right yeah about 65 years now so you're
chief a climate scientist and climate
modeler there's a climate you know in
any given instant but if you have to
predict it you need a computer to help
you do that so a climate modeler is
someone who programs computers to get
some insight as to where things are
versus where they will be and why things
are doing what they do like how how will
the bits and pieces fit together so so
we use the models for that we use the
models for you know explaining you know
how much of this is our fault how much
of it is is natural cycles and then
Gavin it's all your fault we we know
this
well judging from the comments on my
Twitter feed I think I think some people
might agree with you yeah who runs the
model that says all of this is a hoax
and doesn't exist is yeah there there's
no there's no such model
it you do this spoken like a true
conspiracy theorist good for you yeah
that he has to say that yeah exactly wa
so Gavin you know you responded to our
distress call you know we put up the bat
signal over the Gard Institute which is
right just south of Columbia University
just off of Broadway we put up a
distress call because we read that there
was a report a NASA Noah report Noah as
in National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration not Noah the
man Noah working for he he he did know a
lot about
floods he could predict a flood okay he
knew his water that guy so we read in
this report that 2023 was the hottest
year on record indeed could you just
break down for us how is that measured
by how much is it the hottest is this a
trend uh or is it a fluctuation what's
going on we want to keep track of what's
going on on the planet right so we have
lots of uh senses we have lots of we
have weather stations all over the world
we have uh uh ocean uh ships and and
boys floting around measuring uh
everything uh and we want to put all
these things together just just to be
clear I don't know what accent you're
coming from you said but you have boys
in the ocean and I to to booies booies
Oh I thought I thought you had like some
kind of AI or
something my boys my boys they in the
ocean measuring stuff yeah and we've
been trying to put that together since
the 1980s we have the the longest
running time series of of global
temperatures that uh that that anybody
has had um and we started doing that in
the 1980s just to be clear two-thirds of
the Earth surface is covered by ocean
when you say you have ocean buys are
they measuring the ocean temperature at
the locations of those bullies or the
air temperature above the ocean at those
locations they're measuring the uh the
ocean temperature at the surface and
then down to about uh 700 MERS and they
come back up some of them go down a
little bit further and they come back up
and they radio their information so
these are bobbing buoys they are bobbing
buoys yes wow okay put all of that
information together and uh you know
with the historical data you can push
this back to the late 19 century and so
you can get a record of how uh warm the
planet has been uh both globally and and
regionally uh over the last you know 150
odd years and 2023 uh was the warmest of
all of those years by a record margin
right so not just a record but it was
the the biggest new record that has ever
been set uh and so that's uh that's a
very big deal because it comes on the
back of a long-term Trend uh
particularly since the 1970s of steadily
increasing decade by decade temperatures
that are that's driven by what we've
been doing right so the the increases in
carbon dioxide increases in methane and
other greenhouse gases the predictions
were that they it would it would heat it
but not that much right because uh they
we were starting with a linia phase
right but right so you didn't see this
coming but not not even your models no
no we didn't and so that's that's very
discomforting yes it should be we
thought we had a pretty good idea about
how you know the long-term trends uh are
affected by things like the greenhouse
gases so we we we think we've got that
down uh and then we have uh you know 150
years of History where we've seen when
you get an El Nino event at the
beginning of the year then that makes
that year and then when you have a Lino
which is a cool event in the tropical
Pacific when that happens you have a
cool year and El Nino and L so the El
Nino comes from uh it's it's Peruvian
it's the it's the Christ child arriving
at Christmas and and the the El noo
would Peak uh around December January so
that's that's uh it was something that
would arrive uh around the holiday
season and so that's what it was called
and then the the lanin is just the
opposite phase is it is it six months
later uh no so that Peaks around
Christmas as well oh it's just which
whichever one it is that that's doing it
got right so that that Peak around
Christmas that tells you what's going to
happen the next year right and that was
that was a very useful uh heuristic and
and you know and for many many years you
would make a prediction based on that oh
it's going to be a little bit warmer
than the trend a little bit colder than
the trend and it worked and it's not
it's not like it's peaked either because
isn't it like nine more months it will
over the next N9 months or so beyond
this point it'll continue to get hotter
but but this this this year Well in 2023
total failure total fail no no no you
you failed but still in the right
direction okay just total failure would
be oh it's going to drop the temperature
dropped by five degrees and went up by
two and a half degrees that would be
total failure he just well okay so maybe
I'm being a little bit harsh on myself I
mean you know uh but I think you should
be harsh on yourself this is our lives
at stake here I think you got be harsh
on yourself well fair enough fair enough
like it's this is a big deal and so uh
one of the reasons why why we put out
the report and and why we raised the the
notes of cautions that we did is because
when we don't understand something right
there's science to be done but it also
means that our predictions of the future
suddenly become less certain right you
know so we're we're not sure what's
going to happen with 2024 I have I have
a prediction for that based on what used
to happen but like maybe what used to
happen is no longer what's actually
going to happen and that's that's like I
said uncomfortable do you guys factor in
the Solar because the sun is on its way
towards solar Max right now yes it is
and so the sun there was there were
predictions of what the solar cycle
would be and uh and and and this solar
cycle is is kind of ramped up a little
bit faster it's a little bit bigger than
we uh uh than the than the than the
solar people uh predicted uh so there's
still mysteries about how to predict the
solar cycle just to be clear the solar
cycle is 11 years yeah so we had a we
had a solar Min uh a minimum value for
the solar radiation uh around uh you
know 3 four years ago uh and we expect
the maximum uh to occur in two or three
years from right so that's headed up and
so at solar maximum there's higher
energy output of the sun especially at
high energy wavelengths yeah so so it
affect it very um it amplifies ozone uh
so you get these these very large
temperature shifts in in the
stratosphere uh at the surface you you
can see you know it's it's a pretty
small number it's it's around you know
05 to 0.1 Dees celsus so it's about 02
degrees Fahrenheit from from minimum to
maximum so it's not a huge number but it
is a driving force that's in your models
absolutely yeah yeah no it's something
that we've been uh that yeah we've been
looking at that for a long time what
input parameter do you think you either
missed or didn't adjust accurately to
have predicted this this uptick right
great great question um so one of the
most mysterious things that we we don't
really have great data for yet uh is uh
what what the what the particles in the
air are doing so these are called
aerosols um some of them are you know
dust that's been swept up from the
deserts some of it's salt that's been
kind of swept in from the sea uh but a
lot of it is air pollution right so uh
things that we get from burning uh
burning coal or or or or industrial
processes or or sometimes from
agriculture that's putting a lot of
particles pm2.5 sort uh into the air so
these these are particles 2.5 microns
and smaller uh yes yes but this PM
stands for particulate matter
particulate matter and Micron is one 10
the minus 6 one millionth of a one
millionth of a meter so that's 1,000th
of a centimeter 100 yes something so
that's small okay good but the things
that that that do the most amount of
damage when they get into your lungs so
so there's there's uh there's been
changes in uh in in in particulate
matter in the air because we've been
we've been writing laws and saying no
you can't pollute quite as much you have
to be you have to do cleaner stuff so
we've seen uh We've we've seen drops in
in these uh in these aerosols and the
net effect of these aerosols is to cool
the climate a little bit because they
interfere with the sun's radiation they
reflect a lot of it back to space uh and
so the more uh pollution you have the
cooler the climate is and so now we're
removing that pollution and so that's
causing a little bit more warming on top
of the warming from the greenhouse gases
and the and the deforestation and all
okay let me I have to restate what you
just said because people this is
mind-blowing what you're saying is we
are so good at stopping air pollution
that that is a factor in your models
that is actually heating the air because
previously the air pollution was
blocking sunlight from hitting Earth's
surface that's what you're saying that
is what that is what I'm saying hang on
one second I gotta get my way Carol get
me an aerosol can I got to start spray
come on everybody do your so now you're
going to send everybody out there to
just do like I was going to say that
like Neil and I were the problem because
we have hair and you don't and we're
spraying and using dryers and stuff but
it turns out that we're the ones fixing
the we can't win so uh our ability to
keep track of all of these different
things is actually pretty limited we're
actually launching a satellite um in uh
beginning febal Pace uh which for the
first time will produce uh a map of the
composition of all of these different
Aerosoles all these different particles
in the atmosphere across the globe um
and we're we're fingers crossed that
goes well uh but uh but we have the
possibility from then on uh to really uh
kind of nail down those uncertainties uh
by by quite a lot so what you're hinting
at here is in the future where
geoengineering might be a thing um if we
want to cool the Earth abruptly we could
reintroduce aerosols of a particular
size into the atmosphere there are some
real problems with that as a as a as a
solution uh the main one is is that once
you start and it's working you can't
stop like
ever and uh and and when I say ever I
mean like hundreds of years um and so uh
because you're constantly fighting what
how tie the temperature would be and if
you then if you stop then boom boom the
temperature jumps just like it did this
past year right much bigger you don't
know how much to calibrate that to know
exact how yeah you see yes I know words
these are exactly the issu so how would
you calibrate it how would you govern it
what happens when something goes wrong
it's a non-starter for any actual
sustainable responsible solution okay so
rather than leave The Listener thinking
we're all you you please just give us
some positive I was thinking the exact
same thing before we close out okay the
good news is is this so if you take if
you take these same models you take the
same thing and you and you match
everything uh if you suddenly stop
making the problem worse if you suddenly
stop adding carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere it basically stops right this
the the global warming just stops things
don't get any worse and that means means
that anything that we do what we're
doing now we're in charge of what the
future is so the future is determined by
our actions we're not we're not uh we're
not on a runaway train here uh we're not
out of control we have agency and we
control what is going to happen in the
future but we is not an accurate we in
all seriousness because you got half the
population that's fighting the other
half that's trying to deal with it so
the Wii is not really an effective we
okay so you know how how we get the we
to all be collectively pushing in the
same direction that's beyond my payr
right should we be able to do that like
we as a society we control our future
and uh that means that however however
dire the news sounds we have the ability
to make decisions to make it better to
make it stop uh and we can continue to
make those decisions and and we have to
continue to make those decisions and
we're going to be making those decisions
you know from now you know you know for
the rest of this Century uh and we have
to make better decisions if this is
going to slow down and stop and if not
then the upside the global warming is uh
turkeys will base in their own juices
apples will bake on the trees and you'll
be able to grill right on George Foreman
it'll be awesome
so you got some upside there it's I mean
it's doing wonders for uh for for p Noir
in Oregon and Washington State Gavin I
understand that some fraction of the CO2
we put in the air gets absorbed into the
ocean so that's in equilibrium so if we
start dropping CO2 by whatever magic
methods we have isn't it just going to
come back out of the ocean and be no
better than we were before well the idea
is to go back to what we were doing
before but but yes I mean so so uh for
every uh ton that we put into the
atmosphere half of it get sequestered
straight away and half of it is still in
the atmosphere and so when you take out
uh a ton uh you have to take out a half
from the atmosphere and a half from the
ocean as well oh okay it goes both ways
it's not quite symmetric but it's quite
close to being symmet but I am right
that if you take the full ton back out
of the air a half a ton comes back out
of the ocean to fill the air again yes
that's exactly okay so it's a CO2 echo
system that we have to consider but if
you take stuff out it's it it's it stays
out it doesn't but it's just not quite
as effective as uh as you might have
thought initially so Gavin thanks for
responding to our distress signal
because we were all very disturbed
hearing that and uh thanks for scaring
the living out of it you're welcome
it's uh it's my joke way to
go all right Gavin Paul thanks for being
there this has been another St talk
explainer this one on climate and
climate change Neil grass Tyson your
personal asro buiness it keep looking up
[Music]
a